august of 2021 uh we did better than
august of 2019 pre-covet and so it just
shows you that that freedom works and
look people vote with their feet if the
media was right and that these other
states the new yorks and that were the
right way and florida did the wrong way
then you would see people leaving
florida to flock to those states and in
fact you see the opposite
back in 2018 after a hotly contested
election ron desantis was elected
governor of florida
it was a tight race but since then the
governor has dramatically shifted the
political tide in the state of florida
florida now has a majority of republican
voters for the first time in state
history before this ronda santa served
as a congressman here in florida from
2013 to 2018 but it was in 2020 his name
really broke through his leadership
through covet 19 drew the eyes of many
as he was unwilling to accept that
society had to crumble and people's
livelihoods stripped in order to take on
the virus and while so many governors
over the last year
had kept locking people down
florida lifted people up
since then governor desantis has only
grown in popularity
suing the biden administration over the
covet-19 vaccine mandate taking action
against the immigration crisis on the
southern border and even acting to solve
the ongoing national supply chain
interruptions
governor desantis is often reading the
tea leaves of national politics while
defending rights within florida his
action is part of a new sense of state
power that's gone unappreciated for a
very long time
in this episode the governor and i
discuss the biggest lies media has
manufactured about florida and about him
over these past two years just how his
trademark fighting attitude came about
and the surprising upside to all of the
smearing from the mainstream media
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't let big
tech track what you do anonymize your
web browsing at
expressvpn.com governor desantis thanks
so much for giving us your office and
allowing us to welcome to the florida
capitol i got to tell you this is a
great state and thank you for making
this state so great really truly it's
it's an amazing state to be in so why
don't we start from the beginning for
for people who really don't know your
background prior to you leaping onto the
national seen as governor of the state
they they don't live in the state of
florida for example so how did you get
started in politics in the first place
well sometimes people ask me that i say
it was a momentary lapse in judgment
because my first foray into politics was
actually running for congress in 2012
and it was a redistricting year there
was uh two additional seats i happened
to be living in in one of those areas i
had some people tell me that i should
run i started off seven way primary i
had no name id and no no money when i
started and ended up winning by almost
20 points uh in in a six-month campaign
so i was in the congress uh for three
terms and then i got elected as governor
in 2018 here in the great state of
florida and what was sort of your
driving motivation to get involved in in
elected politics because it's not an
easy job and from whereas it doesn't
look like that fun a job to be honest
with you so what what got you started
thinking about doing that well in 2012
that was kind of in the obama era and i
really saw
obama's taking the country in a
direction that was not consistent with
kind of the core founding principles of
the country in fact i even wrote a book
prior to me going into office about it
was read by about a dozen people at the
time but nevertheless it's out there
where i kind of talked about how kind of
the founders conceived this how people
like lincoln and reagan applied applied
these principles and how we were really
veering off that and uh and those were
good fights and and i'm glad we did it
uh but i gotta tell you i look back at
that now it was it's almost kind of
quaint because i think what we're facing
now has been much more aggressive
from the left in terms of across a wide
range of institutions not just the
federal government which of course they
are being very aggressive but big tech
corporate media academia all these
things the bureaucracy all these things
that are happening uh so i got into it
because i saw some things going wrong
and here in florida i think the the good
thing about it is you actually can do
something about it you know in the
congress you're one of 435 so much of
the power is all within the leadership
so a lot of these big bills will be
thousands of page bills they'll do it
behind closed doors and they'll shove it
down the throats over you have time to
read it and and that's kind of how it's
going so if you're somebody has good
ideas and have a lot of energy you kind
of get ground down in washington and so
we were able to do some things but i
looked at the governor and i was like
you know what if you are willing to lead
and you're willing to get out in front
on issues you have an opportunity to do
a lot of good things and so that's what
we've been able to do and i think that i
probably did more as governor my first
two weeks in terms of tangible
long-lasting accomplishments than a
normal congressman can do in a decade it
really is incredible and it is a
reminder i think to a lot of americans
that the states really do matter so if
you're like me and you live your entire
life in california the way you tend to
think of yourself just in terms of state
identity is you're sort of culturally
californian but there's no such thing as
sort of an independent californian
political identity vis-a-vis the federal
government whatever the federal
government does in terms of growing and
expanding that's what california is
doing to you anyway it's actually the
federal government's usually trailing
california then once my family and i
moved here you see that there's an
actual state identity and that state
identity really rests in protecting
liberties that the federal government
may be encroaching upon and in upholding
certain standards that the state of
florida actually sees differently than a
lot of the rest of the country yeah and
i think when i became governor this was
prior to covet of course 2019 i had
three appointments to the florida
supreme court so we had a very liberal
supreme court i replaced three liberal
justices with three conservative
justices so we now have the most
conservative supreme court in the in the
country arguably in the state of florida
that makes a huge difference because
what we do legislatively what i sign
into law it's not going to be struck
down based on state judicial activism as
we started to get into covid and i think
people appreciated when we did that in
florida and when we did some other
things but then when we got into covid
you started to see radically different
approaches to
how did the people that you elect value
your freedoms and your own decision
making in your own liberty and you had
states across the country that just kept
locking people down mandate restriction
and in florida and we made the decision
we want to lift people up we want to
empower them with the tools they need to
make their own decisions to be healthy
to do all that but we've got to have
schools open people have a right to work
you got to have businesses have a right
to operate and so we did that and then i
think you started to see a lot of unrest
in the country the rioting lawlessness
people attacking police defunding police
rogue prosecutors and i think people are
looking like man this is not the type of
community i want to live in so you've
seen a radical difference between a
state like florida where we're valuing
people's freedoms we're supporting safe
communities supporting law enforcement
doing all that and then some of these
other more leftist jurisdictions where
they kept locking down kept violating
people's rights and then seems like the
only rights they respect are the rights
of these criminals that are able to get
away with a lot so the i think the the
distinction between a liberal quote
state and a state like florida has
probably never been so stark because of
all the issues we've dealt with over the
last two years for sure i mean it bust
wide open during covet but i think it's
important to note that you were gaining
you very narrowly squeaked past andrew
gillum in that last gubernatorial
election and then you quickly started
consolidating support by the time that
kova came about you're already polling
very well in this state because of your
gubernatorial strategy your governance
strategy in this state and then covet
hits and suddenly the media decide that
you are satan and andrew cuomo is going
to be the haloed hero of kovit and
anybody who's watching what's going on
understands that it's almost precisely
the reverse in terms of which policy
approach is being taken both on a
statistical level and also on a personal
level i mean andrew cuomo is just
yelling at people and bullying people
and not taking account of anybody's
needs as individual citizens and i got
to tell you it made a huge difference
for me my wife so our story of moving to
florida because we were californian my
wife since she was 12 me since birth and
i'd literally never spent any time
outside of california living anywhere
else except for three years in cambridge
so only blue city's only blue states and
the covet and covet hits they shut down
every park i couldn't take my kids to
the park they shut down every overpass
on mulholland drive they literally shut
down like turnouts on mulholland drive
can take my kids anywhere and then the
riots break out and they tell everybody
you got to stay in your home and they
double curfew you can't go out because
of covet and then they double curfew you
at 6 p.m you got to be home because we
have to make space for people to ride
and we're hearing gunshots in our
community and we're hearing helicopters
overhead and i said to my wife maybe we
should go visit florida i was trying to
push it for two years and finally we
visit here the first day we walk off the
plane it's not overrun with homeless
people i don't see people shooting
heroin into their feet in front of my
children i don't see rioters in the
streets and i make it sound like a
dystopian hellhole california but that's
only because it's become increasingly
like a dystopian hellhole in some of the
major cities and so i think that
honestly maybe the biggest thing was we
we came in we hadn't had dinner as a
couple out at a restaurant for two
months they shut down all the
restaurants in l.a the first night we
were here we went to a restaurant they
were still eating outdoors we ate
outdoors at the restaurant because there
was no evidence to suggest it was a
problem
and i turned to my wife and i said we
could be doing this all the time
and it's and it's a tribute to you know
what the state of florida is well the
thing is is i mean just you know your
freedom to do that's important but just
think about all the people whose
livelihoods depend on having an open
economy and i remember with the
restaurants faucis was railing about the
restaurants uh probably some time at the
end of summer 2020 and i'm just thinking
to myself he wants all this closed and i
was like i'm going to highlight what
this means so i did an event at a
steakhouse down in south florida and
yeah we had the proprietor there the
owner to talk about thanks governor
sanders for business but i had the
butcher there he'd been there 24 years
said i don't feed my family if we're not
open i had the bartender i had the
servers i had all these people
throughout the organization come through
and in a state like florida if we had
done like california lockdown we have a
service based economy between our
lodging our our parks our restaurants
and so we were able to keep those afloat
in fact august of 2021
we did better than august of 2019
pre-covet hotel reservations receipts in
terms of revenue restaurant reservations
and so it just shows you that that
freedom works and look people vote with
their feet if the media was right and
that these other states the new yorks
and that were the right way and florida
did the wrong way then you would see
people leaving florida to flock to those
states and in fact you see the opposite
and so i think it's been interesting
because the media's tried to gaslight on
this and it's obviously nobody believes
what the corporate press says anymore
because people are beating a a pathway
here and even
these lockdown governors and lockdown
mayors they would lock down their state
or lock down their city and then they'd
show up in my state out at the pool
drinking a margarita and it was like
clockwork that that would happen
throughout cobit so in a second i want
to ask you about how you came up with
your coveted strategy because it wasn't
a pure red blue thing at the very
beginning there were some red states
maryland for one that sort of locked
down in terms of the governor uh ohio
was much more locked down but you
decided not to go that route i want to
ask about that in one second first let's
talk about a great gift that you can
give to your family with the holidays
quickly approaching give your loved ones
the invaluable gift of having their
cherished memories preserved forever let
me tell you about an amazing amazing
gift for the holidays legacy box it's
the best way to preserve your past if
you're like most people there's one box
you run back into your burning house to
grab it's usually that box that's filled
with like videotapes film reels wedding
photos the sentimental meaningful
irreplaceable stuff that you don't have
on digital but here is the thing you can
save that stuff from being destroyed by
floods or fires but time will destroy it
unless you grab all that stuff and you
send it in to legacy box fill your
legacy box with old home movies and
pictures they will do the rest
digitizing their moments onto a thumb
drive the cloud or dvd it's like magic
why use legacy box each item is hand
digitized by a team of over 200 trained
technicians right here in the united
states their exclusive barcoded online
tracking system provides up to 12 email
updates along the way legacy box has
been the industry leader in
professionally digitizing family
memories for over a decade i did this
for my parents i went into their garage
took all their stuff dumped it in the
legacy box sent it off when it came back
digitized it was preserved for all time
legacy box is giving our listeners early
access to their black friday sale visit
legacybox.com shapiro to unlock an
exclusive discount for our black friday
sale that's
legacybox.com shapiro for their best
deal of the year legacybox.com shapiro
okay so let's talk about how you came up
with sort of your covid approach because
obviously there were some red governors
who decided to go in the more lockdown
direction uh there are a few blue
governors like jared palace in colorado
who's gonna be a little bit looser but
but you from the very get-go were
analyzing the data and you were looking
at the data and you basically said from
the start that we need to protect the
elderly and we need to make sure that
everybody else can get back to work and
and re-enter something approaching
normal life how did you come up with
that strategy well i think there were
two main things i mean one is we were
all given these models about the
hospitalization spikes that would happen
and they were literally predicting like
10 times the number of patients then we
even had hospital beds in in all the
states throughout the united states i
mean hundreds of thousands of patients
they were predicting in florida you know
we've got about 65 000 licensed beds at
a given time and so you're looking at
that in new york they were predicting
even more the ventilators all the stuff
but then in real time i'm looking okay
march 21st they said we're gonna have
four thousand we have one thousand next
day you know we have one thousand and
ten instead of forty three hundred and
so the models clearly were wrong and the
whole reason this quotes 15 days to slow
the spread was to prevent hospital
overcrowding and it was clear to me that
yes a place like new york if you had an
outbreak like that it would bend but it
wasn't clear to me that it would break
and i think that's been true throughout
covet then the other thing was you
started to get research out of stanford
looking at the cerro prevalence data in
other words how many people have
actually had it and what they found was
most people that had it had modest or no
symptoms and so the mortality rate was
much less than what the who had said
yeah high you know relatively high for
for elderly people if you have certain
comorbidities but for the vast majority
of people you know it would be something
that would likely not present the risk
of hospitalization or death and so i
thought those two factors meant you got
to have society open we can target
protection to people that need it to
elderly and so that was initially making
sure nursing homes were not having paid
we barred sending sick patients back
into nursing homes make sure we
protected that you know i said national
guard to do tests on nursing homes if
there was ever an outbreak we prioritize
elderly for vaccination and then we've
done the monoclonal antibodies where
we're getting early treatment to people
and and we're 100 about doing that but
to kneecap your whole society and here's
the thing it doesn't stop the virus it'd
be one thing if we could all just go in
a cave for two weeks and the virus would
disappear but that is not true so you're
gonna have to deal with it and i think
we're finding that out now because you
look some of these very highly
vaccinated countries in europe are
having massive spikes vermont in the
united states hitting records so that's
just the reality and i think that living
with it
and not destroying your society was
something that that made sense and quite
frankly was what the literature up until
coveted for pandemic preparedness had
said they always said don't let the fear
overcome society you have to keep things
going you've got to keep people in a
good state of mind give them accurate
information and it seemed like our
leaders like fauci they would try to
ratchet up the fear and they ended up
spooking a lot of people and there's
some people that really haven't gotten
over that even today particularly in
some of those deep blue enclaves it's
100 true i mean i have family members
who are very paranoid about covet after
being triple vast and and i think that
that that sort of mentality has pervaded
because when you have the the highest
members the highest scientific
institutions in the land telling you
over and over and over what risks you're
undergoing by seeing your grandkids
post-vaccination you know a lot of
people take that to heart were you
freaked out at all but at the very
beginning by the amount of media
blowback that you got because you would
imagine that in a normal society that
there would be at least a little bit of
tolerance for the fact that nobody knew
anything about the virus what we did
know suggested that there were several
different strategies that could be
undertaken to be charitable to some of
the other folks who took a different
strategy and then as the data began to
emerge it became clear that florida was
actually not collapsing that florida was
actually doing relatively well next to
states like california and well really
next states like new york and new jersey
particularly and and yet the media
decided that you were the villain of
covid from the get-go from the jump you
were the villain of covid did you find
that surprising at all
no because i think they started
weaponizing covet against trump and i
think their their meta narrative was you
know trump was bad that's why they
elevated people like
like cuomo because they were saying this
is true leadership opposed to trump so i
think that was and then me as a
republican governor and in a key state i
think i was target number two and so i
think that that's just typical what they
do the corporate press creates partisan
narratives they don't care about the
facts i mean there's a lot of facts
about covet they still won't recognize
to this day but i also think there was a
lot of pressure on the media from some
of these scientific elites they didn't
want a control group because they were
advocating policies that were going to
have a hugely detrimental effect to the
social fabric
and if you could show a sweden or a
florida or some of these other places
that didn't pay those terrible costs and
still had similar outcomes in terms of
covid then it would show that what they
were advocating uh was not only
misguided but it was actually harmful
and i think that was part of the reason
it was you know you have these
scientists like jay bhattacharya and
martin calder from they will speak out
they get absolutely killed because i
think they just these people don't want
to have any evidence that people can
point to to say they were wrong about
this from the beginning and in fact if
you look the corporate press has been
wrong about this time and time again
they shield for lockdowns the lockdowns
didn't stop covet they said force
masking would end the pandemic in the
summer of 2020 didn't end the pandemic
they said if 50 were vaccinated you
wouldn't have surges people like fauci
said that that obviously isn't true so
time and time they said schools needed
to be closed they said schools would
drive the pandemic if schools were open
well florida we had schools open and it
didn't do that and so they've been wrong
time and time again but at the end of
the day they see all this through a
partisan prism i reject their worldview
they view me i think as a threat to
their worldview and so i think that i'm
a target but i tell you
i view that positively i think that when
you're
fighting back against leftist narratives
and leftist policies
if they're attacking you it means
because you're getting traction and i
think people around the country started
looking to florida and they were like
hey you know this guy's doing the right
thing and that's why people have poured
in here and not just people moving here
we're by far the number one vacation
destination now we've always been a top
one but i can't tell you the number of
people i've run into over the last year
and a half from lockdown states that are
just like thank you governor for letting
me be here for two weeks and be sane
instead of suffering under some of the
draconian policies that they were having
to in these left-wing states i'm amazed
at the number of lies the media told
over the course of this pandemic about
you and about florida particularly so
they lied when they said for example
that monoclonal antibodies were they
didn't work they lied when they
suggested that you were falsifying the
death data which they kept suggesting
over and over and over they lied when
they said that you were killing kids
because you were telling parents that
they didn't need to mask their kids or
that masks should be optional for their
kids i mean they just lied routinely
throughout the pandemic they they
continue to lie about the idea that
you're somehow downplaying the efficacy
of vaccines when i was here when the
vaccines rolled out and you were telling
everybody who could get vaccinated and
you were prioritizing the most
vulnerable and here's the thing though
so like let's take the school masking we
put the kids in school
and it's gone down 90 some percent since
the kids went into school and these are
overwhelmingly kids not wearing masks so
they were wrong about that they will
never admit that they will never come to
terms with that data the vaccines they
attack me because i said the efficacy
wanes after a certain time now fauci is
out there saying that he says you need a
regimen because after six months or so
people are more liable to get infected
the the clinical data for pfizer was 95
protection against infection and 100
protection against hospitalization and
death that may be true initially but the
protection wanes and so i pointed that
out months ago because israel's data
showed that the uk showed it and now our
data in the united states shows it and
they say that somehow i was downplaying
when all i was doing was accurately
describing what we were talking about
that was one of the reasons why we
needed to do the monoclonals because
people that were fully vaccinated were
getting infected in florida this summer
and many of these people are the most
vulnerable people and so they have a
breakthrough infection they go they get
it and most of them invariably
were very happy and with that treatment
but the monoclonal blies they told that
may have killed some people because we
went out there it was clinically proven
and i would say of all the things that
have been put out this has performed a
hundred percent in line with the
clinical trial data it reduces
hospitalizations in deaths by the amount
that they said it would and we have so
many first-hand examples of that but
they acted like this was some type of
scam that we were trying to provide
early treatment there very well may be
people who believe these media
narratives who got coveted and rejected
seeking monoclonal antibody treatments
and may have had a negative outcome so
it just shows you they're more
interested in pursuing a narrative than
in informing the public in a factual way
when even members of the public's lives
could be at stake here with a covet
infection and early treatment let's talk
about the conflict between the state of
florida and the federal government so
the biden administration uh has been
very overt in its opposition to you
personally you've had jen sackey ripping
on you from the white house press room
you've had president biden making not
particularly oblique references about
you during press conferences that he
manages to get through and um and the
the sort of ratcheting up of the of the
battle between the state of florida and
the federal government has become very
clear to a lot of folks frankly it's
been encouraging to me because i think
that states actually need to stand up to
the predations of the federal government
at this point but can you give us sort
of some insight as to is there anything
going on behind the scenes is there any
conversation between the governor's
office and the white house well i would
say anything that comes up you know they
will try to politicize it uh education
health i mean you name it i mean that's
just how they are that's how they're
wired and so for example the monoclonal
antibodies they at the begin when we had
the height of our summer wave they cut
our monoclonal antibodies i mean we had
i rolled out a very successful program
we had 25 sites people were getting it
they had great results and they cut i
had to go with a find another company
glaxosmithkline do a separate deal to be
able to paper over the decline now
they've cut it so much but our our
infections have gone down even more that
we're ending up in good shape at this
point but they deliberately did that
they said there was no shortage they
were just doing it for quote equity
purposes and you got to wonder why you
would do that you also look at what
they're doing with with the contractor
mandates and the and the osha mandates i
mean look i think that that is more
directed at states like florida because
some of these big blue states will
probably impose those mandates on their
own they know we we will not do that and
so we're fighting uh back against that
very strongly we have a special session
of the legislature we have the lawsuits
across the board about all those things
uh but they don't respect uh states like
florida's uh prerogatives and the fact
is things like schools they try to butt
into you know we have conflicts where
some school boards weren't following our
state's parents bill of rights and so
the state board of education took the
salaries away from the elected
politicians
biden comes in and they put the money
back in they're bailing out politicians
who are disobeying state law how is that
an appropriate use of the federal
government and we're going to address
that in our special session but time and
time again they want to come in and do
it i think that they've really failed on
this cutting the monoclonal antibodies
went over like a lead balloon in florida
their uh obsession with force masking
five-year-olds uh has not gone over well
i mean i think most parents look at it
now and they understand kids are doing
well without this and and they need to
be able to do that
and so i think it's not worked for them
but i think this is just their viewpoint
biden is not really tethered by the
constitution i think he's got a lot of
radical elements in his administration
that push him to do certain things and i
don't think he has the wherewithal or
the leadership ability to say no you
know
even obama would tell the lefties that
sometimes that they were going too far
bill clinton would sometimes
biden's not doing that he just doesn't
have the capacity to do it and so
they're really pushing him in a
direction i think that is very dangerous
for the country and quite frankly shows
his presidential candidacy was a fraud
because he said he was going to unite
the country he demagogued trump on covid
he said he would shut down the virus
that hasn't happened and he said he
would unite the country and in fact on
policy he's been the most divisive
president of my lifetime more divisive
than the other democrats even that have
been in office so let's talk about biden
in his presidency for a second so
president biden obviously is really
deeply underwater at this point his poll
numbers look really bad they're in the
low 40s maybe high 30s his vice
president is somehow even worse off
despite the fact that she's been
completely absent from the national
scene while not visiting the southern
border uh and uh and this this
administration seems to be in a bit of
disarray but as you mentioned they keep
doubling down on this policy and as they
keep doubling down on their policies it
seems like core to that policy is
attempting to cram down national
mandates on state so what what tools do
you have as a governor of a major state
at your disposal in order to in order to
hamper that so take for example the
vaccine mandate so they're trying to
cram down this vaccine mandate which
essentially forces all companies with
more than 100 employees either backs
their employees or test them once a week
or fire them and they're they're trying
to do this via osha it's
unconstitutional our company has filed a
lawsuit in the sixth circuit court of
appeals about that because our
headquarters is over in in tennessee but
what sort of tools do states have at
their disposal to resist the federal
government when they go this far well i
think we have legal tools and and
legislative tools so the legal tools
we've sued as well the 11th circuit you
have the great fifth circuit decision
that came down for the stay i think that
that's probably going to stick which
will be great but we're also having the
legislature come in and provide
substantive protections for employees in
the state of florida no one should have
to choose between their job and this jab
if it's something that's good for you
and you want to do that's fine but you
shouldn't be forced out of work and then
just think about who this apply to
nurses truck drivers all these they've
been working the whole time they've been
working the whole time and now all of a
sudden you're going to potentially cast
them aside so we're providing those
protections legislature is going to
debate some other things we've actually
talked about taking some abide in
stimulus money and paying off the osha
fines for the business that don't comply
although having this stay in the court
you know may make that uh be something
that we don't do we also in terms of the
illegal immigration so he's got a
massive border surge that he's invited
because he basically uh overruled
trump's policies that were working and
so i sent people in june and july to
help governor abbott and my guys in
florida they're interdicting a lot of
these guys now if they had drugs or they
were trafficking they'd get arrested and
texas would take them but if they were
just illegally crossing the border our
guys would turn them over to the feds
the feds would just release them or
they'd put them on a bus or something
like that so we're looking from a
defensive posture in florida if they're
dumping people in the middle of the
night here you know i want to be able to
have an opportunity to do that and maybe
transport them elsewhere we also are
looking at maybe penalizing the
contractors who are facilitating which
is effectively violations of federal law
by transporting people who are in the
country illegally so we're looking at
all of those and of course we're suing
biden on his catch and release policies
as well you know they don't even really
publish the policies they just kind of
behave recklessly and to try to avoid
any type of judicial oversight but i can
tell you having 200 000 people cross
every month that's basically a
medium-sized american city uh that
they're importing illegally from all and
not just mexico in fact very
minor of mexico there's over 100
countries because people know biden's
president you can get to that southern
border you're home free so one of the
things i think a lot of conservatives
love about your governorship and about
your sort of persona publicly uh is your
combativeness is your willingness to go
right at the media where did you pick
that up and why have republicans many
republicans failed to participate in
that sort of combativeness for so long
do you think well i think it's just a
matter of just understanding kind of
what time it is now if this was a media
that was dedicated to fact factual
reporting gathering facts putting it out
then you know you may want to behave a
little bit differently but in fact i
mean they're highly partisan and not
only they highly partisan they really
are detached from reality and from facts
at this point their main goal is to
pursue their narratives and so if you
have facts that undercut their
narratives they are either going to
ignore those facts or actively try to
smother those facts and so that's just
where we're at and so these corporate
outlets
you know i think in terms of what
they've done to their reputations with
the russia collusion report i mean they
were manufacturing that whole story they
gave each other pulitzer prizes for
reporting on a false conspiracy theory
and so if you had asked me 10 years ago
about the media i wouldn't have said
they were our friend but i'd say you
know they have a liberal bias you got to
be careful of that but but now you just
got to understand those corporate
outlets are so untethered from the truth
they are so highly partisan uh that
that's the way you have to you have to
treat them and so when they're trying to
pursue narratives i don't let them get
away with it if they're trying to just
get information to try to do a hit piece
i don't let them get away with it and
the thing is is when you have the facts
on your side it's very difficult for
them because a lot of them all they do
is recycle whatever the narrative de
jure of the day is but i would say
republicans have to understand you know
don't try to get these people to like
you okay that's not what they're going
to do you got to understand what their
role is i think quite frankly there's a
lot of conservative outlets where you
can get great messages out and i don't
believe in this where the corporate
outlets will point to your outlet or fox
or all these and act like oh well
they're so the fact is conservative
outlets are much more accurate in what
they're reporting every single day
because you got to be if you're not you
have the weight of the world that comes
down on you so you have to do that and
so that's just the reality and i can
tell you the most of the stuff that gets
put out in these corporate outlets
against florida is fatally flawed
usually six ways from sunday so that's
just the reality and i think we've got
to understand that and as conservatives
we just have to govern ourselves
accordingly but the good news is
most people don't trust these folks
anymore you know i think even 10 years
ago people knew the media had a bias but
if something was put on the news i think
they thought that it was probably true
otherwise it wouldn't have been run at
least in some now i think they they
believe
they're trying to trick me
they assume it's false unless there's a
strong evidence to show what the media
is saying is true and i think that
that's a lot of great progress because
that's just the fact that's where we
should be you know as a society is how
we view these people so in a second i
want to ask you your gubernatorial
strategy your governing strategy and
your legislative strategy has been very
aggressive in pursuit of certain goals
and i'm going to ask where you draw the
line between sort of a libertarian
perspective and a conservative
perspective and get to that in just one
second first the holidays are
approaching you might be thinking about
how you are going to save some extra
cash well i have a solution maybe you
haven't thought of consolidate your high
interest credit card balances to a lower
rate and save with lightstream
lightstream offers credit card
consolidation loans with rates starting
at 4.98 apr with auto pay and excellent
credit which is a lot lower than the
national average interest on credit
cards over 19 to apr plus your rate is
fixed so as rates continue to rise your
low rate will not budge there are no
fees you can even get your money as soon
as the day you apply lightstream
believes that people with good credit
deserve a better loan experience that's
exactly what they deliver just for my
listeners right now apply to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get that
discount is go to lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from 4.98 percent apr to 19.99 apr
and include a 0.50 autopay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information that's
shapiro go check them out right now
so let's talk about sort of the debate
that's happening on the right it's
really interesting there's some fun
philosophical debates happening on the
right between sort of the libertarian
oriented side of the right and the more
conservative oriented side of the right
the libertarians saying things like well
to take an example when it comes to
companies deciding whether their
employees to get facts that that's a
decision that should be left to
companies because you know you can't
tell anybody to bake the cake and you
also can't tell anybody whether their
employees ought to be vexed or not
those sorts of debates how do you decide
you know whether libertarians are right
that liberty got to be the first concern
or whether conservatives are right that
the sort of preconditions for liberty
need to be set
by the government in certain cases in
order to provide that tyranny doesn't
happen even even from companies yeah no
i mean i think my job is to protect
people's freedoms but i understand that
your freedoms can be infringed yes by
government but it can also be infringed
in this modern society
by big corporate power
and it's also about the type of society
you want so for example we banned
vaccine passports in the state of
florida many months ago it was just
getting off the ground in places and my
view was i want a free state i don't
want a biomedical security state now
some say well if a company wants you to
show your papers to be able to go to a
movie why shouldn't they have the right
to do it and my view is i care more
about the rights of my citizens to be
able to live in a free society and if
that takes hold in a society where
companies start to do that we then i
think you know lose freedom as a society
and quite frankly uh if that would
happen our tourism would go down as a
result and there'd be places that were
not requiring that that would probably
be heard so we did that you look at
something like a big tech
massive monopolies that control a huge
amount of speech in this country you
know i believe there should be
protections for individuals right to
speak i mean they hold themselves out as
being open forums they get liability
protection from the from the federal
government and yet they'll turn around
into platform if you say the wrong thing
or or
censor what you say if it's not in
accordance with their narrative so
they're not applying their terms of
service in a way that's fair so i think
people should be able to have the
ability to go in and bring consumer
fraud actions against big tech and so
and then also i just say taking a step
back
liberty if you just say like don't do
anything the problem is you know if
you're opposed to woke ideology leftism
all these things that's the dominant
ideology in most of these institutions
in our country it's not just the federal
government in the bureaucracy although
of course it is it's big tech it's
corporate media it's academia it's now
corporate america more and more who are
really embracing this so if you say
you're not going to do anything you're
basically seeding the field to the left
at this day and age much different than
maybe would have been like in like the
1920s where you had a stronger civil
society and there wasn't a need maybe to
to do as much in certain respects uh
well now you're in a situation where you
have people's freedoms being violated
all the time and you may need to do it
so you mentioned social media there and
and big tech obviously it's had a major
impact on how people view the world what
big tech allows what big tech does not
allow one of your signature efforts was
to allow liability for big tech when
they for example crack down on people
solely for political reasons and uh that
that's a measure that you're going to go
back and and rewrite now because there's
some court battle over that what do you
think can be done about big tech
realistically speaking to to sort of
make them open up and be what they were
originally purported to be well at the
state level we really have these
consumer fraud actions i mean that's
probably the best thing that we can do
the good thing about that that's not a
government agency telling them what they
have to allow or not allow it's an
individual who may have been aggrieved
that can go in and say wait a minute i
made this statement you took it down but
you didn't take down these other
statements that are same subject matter
just may be consistent with your
perspective and so i think it's a better
way to do it now ultimately federally
you know you're going to look at things
like section 230 you're going to look at
potentially breaking up or limiting the
size of some of these companies because
they have huge huge power over the
market i think traditionally antitrust
has been
about cost like they can raise the price
that's what we're concerned about yeah
that may be something we're concerned
about but i think in a republican form
of government for them to be able to
control so much power political power
effectively uh with really no check that
would be a reason for us to come in um
and provide a little bit of sanity in
this marketplace so we've been talking a
lot about what the state of florida has
done providing a different model than
say new york or california one of the
things that you've mentioned and it's
been happening obviously is this big
sword a lot of republicans a lot of
conservatives independents moving down
to below the mason-dixon line moving to
red states a lot of people who are on
the left kind of staying up there and
this big sort is good for a lot of
people who are living in the red states
it also does raise the question of what
you think the future of the country is
going to look like because
very often if people don't live near
anybody who disagrees with them and they
don't know anybody who disagrees with
them they tend to sort of hunker down
and then it becomes sort of a battle at
the top level for who gets to control
everybody else now the conservative
vision presumably is if they got control
of the federal government in all of its
auspices the conservatives they would
loosen up the grip of the federal
government we wouldn't force blue states
to live like red states the blue states
obviously don't have the same sort of
aspirations they kind of want to force
red states to live like blue states but
what do you think is the future of the
country as it seems like a lot of the
top-line issues that used to unite us
are now dividing us well you definitely
are seeing migration that's being driven
more and more uh by philosophy and and
basically by ideology because you're in
certain areas and if you have a
conservative perspective i mean law and
order no in some of these places
obviously lock down infringement all
these other things that's enough for
people to say you know this is in like
florida we've seen huge migration it's
not just for low taxes because we've
always had lower taxes and what you're
seeing is people coming and people ask
me well what's the complexion of this in
terms of the political demography when i
got elected governor there are almost
300 000 more registered democrats in
florida than republicans now for the
first time in the issue of state we
actually have more registered
republicans than democrats so you're
looking almost 300 000 just since
november of 2018 and at this clip you
know we're gonna exceed that um probably
ten thousand maybe a month going on that
so so that is just the reality and i
think you're going to continue to see
that i think states like florida states
like texas states like tennessee
arizona those are places where people
are moving to
from these blue areas the question is is
what then does that make the blue areas
even more blue because i think in like
new jersey we probably would have won
that governor's race do you have so many
people republicans that have moved out
of new jersey in the last four years i
mean just think if you didn't have maybe
30 40 000 and you're seeing it out of
the midwest and all these other places
so um so i think that that's a trend
that's going to continue you know at the
national level i mean the problem i
think that we're seeing you know from as
conservatives is you know the
government's just been weaponized uh
basically against people who dissent
from the regime which is a little bit
different than maybe a few decades ago
and you may have a president that you
disagree with but now how these agencies
are acting how so much policy is now
designed to basically uh benefit kind of
the people that that vote for them but
really to turn conservatives almost into
second class citizens i mean think about
what the agenda would have been if they
would have a couple more senators make
d.c a state so you have two permanent
radical left democrat senators
abolish the electoral college so
california gets to elect the president
they wanted to federalize ballot
harvesting ballot fraud overrule voter
id laws you know at the state level
and pack the supreme court so you could
have a leftist majority legislating
under the auspices of constitutional
interpretation those are not issues that
a middle-income family sitting over
their dinner table is talking about
they're talking about gas prices
inflation all these other things that is
an agenda of a more radicalized left
that really wants to make conservative
america you know inferior citizens and
so the stakes uh in terms of what goes
on at the federal government have
probably not been higher in my lifetime
and i think it's something that um
ultimately you're going to have to have
people on the right be able to beat this
back win some decisive victories and
certainly i think there's a strong
majority in this country that you know
not that the country is is right wing 60
percent but i would say center right
rejecting things like wokeness and all
the nonsense that you've seen bubble up
to the surface over the last many years
so in a second i want to ask you just on
a personal level how you how you deal
with all of this i mean it's it's a it's
a very busy life and you have a bunch of
young kids and and you have a family
someone ask about that first let's talk
about your hiring these days did you
know there are right now like 10 million
job openings in the united states but
only 7.6 million unemployed job seekers
that issue is being worsened due to a
mismatch of employers and qualified
talent so employers are having to go
above and beyond to entice people to
want to work for them by offering
benefits ranging from legal services to
pet insurance if you can relate to any
of these challenges with growing your
team you need to try zip recruiter right
now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com ben guest zip recruiter
uses powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates with your job
then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
that encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the united states
based on g2 ratings zip recruiters
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com
ben guest that's ziprecruiter.com
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire once again try them at
ziprecruiter.com
ben guest
alrighty so on a personal level how do
you deal with all this you've taken an
enormous amount of crap for the last
several years your schedule is insanely
busy i've been talking to some of your
legislators over here from your party
and you guys have a packed agenda for
the next term
what does your day look like
well i mean it's busy i mean so we have
three kids under five uh i got a
daughter that's almost five son three
and a half and then a daughter that's
about a year and a half and so that's a
very fun age but it's also very tiring
and so
we do our thing in terms of with the
state when you're governor you're
governor 24 7. i mean i may not be
sitting in this office i may be doing an
event somewhere i may just be at the
executive residence but your governor
things happen all the time so you're
always on call um
but we have a big state too so i mean
it's not like you know i just go to like
a one city all the time i mean i'm all
over the place we do it i think that's
the only way you can do it to be
successful the good thing though is when
i was in congress you're in dc i mean i
just sleep on my couch as a member
but when we had our first child you know
you're there and you want to be home and
so as busy as i am in florida
governor is more family friendly because
i can visit two three cities i could
still be back at home for dinner and
that makes a big big difference
you know my wife the first lady does a
great job
with just everything she's great for the
state great spouse great mother you know
she's now you know battling the the
breast cancer which been it was a very
difficult thing for us when the news hit
and it's been um it's been difficult but
i'll tell you uh and you have good days
and bad days but i think she's uh
fighting through it very effectively um
and so you kind of throw that on top of
everything else and i would say
certainly it's been been a wild ride but
the last probably month and a half since
the diagnosis came down you know has has
really been surreal uh but you know her
view is is you know i'm gonna get
through it and you know i'm going to
come back better than ever so so i and i
think that will happen i'll tell you the
people that have reached out to her uh
from not just around florida but all
over the country uh it's been really
inspiring it's definitely boosted her
spirits because i can tell you before we
announced this publicly you know it was
we were a difficult spot she was in a
difficult spot you know i was very very
down for having to you know have this
happen to someone you know my wife uh
but then when the outpouring came in i
mean it really made a difference it made
a difference for all of us but it
definitely made a difference for casey
we're certainly all praying for casey
and uh yeah best wishes to her let's
let's talk for a second about sort of
your philosophical influences so how did
you become conservative in the first
place you know it's interesting i um
when i was growing up i i grew up in
west central florida in a town called
dunedin in pinellas county the tampa bay
area and you know i wasn't necessarily i
didn't have a political philosophy for
per se um but and then i got i was a
baseball player so i got recruited to
play baseball various places i ended up
going to yale to play baseball it was a
massive culture shock i mean you know i
was a blue collar kid you know i go to
you know i'm a catholic i go to church
every sunday you know i just
instinctively loved america
just because that was what you did i go
up there the motto was for god for
country for yale but yet they were
actively opposed to anybody that
believed in god they hated the united
states i mean everything was about how
bad the country was and i'm just
thinking to myself like this is not
something that i want to sign up for so
i think the just how being exposed to
leftism kind of raw leftism really
turned me off and then when i was in
college really was um somebody that that
never accepted uh the the leftism of
academia by the time i got into like
harvard law school i was set like and
that's a liberal place but there was
nothing that they were going to be able
to do to change me at that point do you
have any particular thinkers that you
like to read or favorite books that sort
of changed your well i mean i think it's
just you know i think you look at um you
know just the religious tradition of
western civilization um and so you know
i was a kid that grew up i mean i i went
to catholic school in elementary school
um you know i went to public middle in
high school but continued with with that
and that's just been a foundation for me
and then i think i really studied a lot
of our founding fathers i studied the
influences that that that caused them to
want to revolt and then create the
constitution and so you look at all the
things they did i mean they they knew i
mean obviously they knew they knew locke
they knew
all the all the ancient greeks and
romans they knew that like the back of
their hand and so to watch them create
this country you know on the on the
shoulders of kind of those influences
was something that i really really
studied deeply well governor desantis it
really is a pleasure to be here and i
want to thank you for welcoming me to
the state and and so many others the
state is fantastic and we hope that you
stick around as governor for for quite a
while governor desantis really thank you
so much for joining the show thank you
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover executive
producer jeremy boring and our assistant
director is pavel wydowsky our guests
are booked by caitlin maynard editing is
by jim nicholl audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina title graphics are by cynthia
angulo the ben shapiro show sunday's
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]